I mentioned at the top of the show in our
first segment, sort of taking a big picture
look at what's going on and the options, the
two possible paths forward that the country
is facing right now in the wake of the riotous
insurrection from last week.
I talked about what's happening within the
Republican Party.
And you have some Republicans that are bailing
on Donald Trump and you have some that are
not.
And I made the point that the people that
are bailing with 11 days to go, this is not
an act of courage.
This is an act of self-preservation.
And it's really important that we not allow
these people to rehabilitate their reputations
because they've been part of it for a very
long time and only now when it is relatively
safe politically to do so.
They are saying this is too much, that's too
much, too much.
I can't be a part of it.
But that being said, there is a growing list
of Republicans that now want to remove Donald
Trump.
And I think it's important to understand that
this is different.
We did not see this during the first impeachment,
as it looks like we are heading towards a
second impeachment of the president.
So let's talk about it a little bit and go
through some of the instances.
Republican Senator Lisa Murkowski, a sitting
senator, Republican from the state of Alaska,
says that she wants Trump out and may even
leave the Republican Party altogether over
this.
Now, if she does leave, she's not saying she
would become a Democrat.
There's every indication that if she were
to leave the Republican Party, she would be
an independent.
But she put out a statement pointing out that
Donald Trump incited this mob to unlawfully
breach the Capitol, led to injured and in
fact, law enforcement deaths, put members
of Congress in danger, put the vice president
in danger, interfered with the duty of Congress
to count the electoral votes.
And she goes on to say that Donald Trump indeed
should leave.
Lisa Murkowski saying, I think he should leave.
He said he's not going to show up.
He's not going to appear at the inauguration.
He hasn't been focused on what's going on
with covid.
He's either been golfing or he's been inside
the Oval Office fuming and throwing every
person who's been loyal and faithful to him
under the bus, starting with the vice president.
He only wants to stay there for the title.
She says he only wants to stay there for his
ego.
He needs to get out.
He needs to do the good thing.
But I don't think he's capable of doing a
good thing.
So an important statement from Republican
Lisa Murkowski.
She's not saying she would vote to convict.
She's saying Trump should leave, Trump should
resign.
And it's not clear that there's even a one
percent chance that he does that.
And, yes, she also went on to say that the
her future may not be in the Republican Party,
but it's not in the Democratic Party either.
Every indication is Lisa Murkowski would become
an independent if she were to leave the party.
But it's something it's still a big deal.
Another current Republican Senator, Pat Toomey,
says remove Trump.
He's actually saying it is time to remove
Donald Trump.
Take a listen to what he had to say yesterday
on one of the Sunday shows.
Your Republican colleague, Senator Lisa Murkowski
of Alaska, says President Trump should resign.
She said, quote, He's caused enough damage.
Do you agree?
Yeah, I do I think at this point, with just
a few days left, it's the best path forward,
the best way to get this person in the rearview
mirror for us, that could happen immediately.
I'm not optimistic it will, but I do think
that would be the best way forward.
So that is a big deal that that that that
is huge.
There's no way around that.
Yes.
We're down to nine days left.
But that is still you know, it's starting
to point to what we had.
You know, when Richard Nixon was about to
be impeached, Republicans got together and
they went to him and they said, this is it,
this is it.
You're getting impeached and we're going to
convict.
And at that time, circumstances were very
different.
And it's it's almost cliche and overly simplistic
to say Republicans then were willing to do
what Republicans today aren't willing to do.
The Republican Party is also dramatically
more radical today than it was.
I think that today's Republican Party also
wouldn't have said to Nixon, it's time to
go, unfortunately.
But that was when there was something that
was beyond the line today.
Nothing seems to be beyond the line for most
Republicans.
So good for Pat Toomey.
However, he then says in the same interview
that that voting for Trump made sense at the
time.
After Wednesday's attack, he took to the Senate
floor to denounce President Trump as a demagog.
But we should note, you voted for him in November
for the second time, even after Charlottesville.
Right.
Even after he used force to clear Lafayette
Square for a photo op, even after he embraced
Kuhnen conspiracy theorists, many of whom
were in that mob.
I'm not saying you bear any responsibility
for what happened on Wednesday, but do you
regret not doing more to stop somebody you're
now now calling a demagog, who's pretty obviously
been a demagog for his entire political career?
It Jake, I don't think there's any doubt at
all, is not in my mind that the president's
behavior after the election was wildly different
than his behavior before he descended into
a level of madness and engaged in activity
that was just absolutely unthinkable and unforgivable.
For four years, he often put out offensive
and objectionable tweets, actually, sometimes
dozens a day.
I never felt and I still don't think that
my job was to be his the editor of his Twitter
feed, although I was very often critical.
So you can see the direction that that's that's
going, right.
I mean, these are pathetic defenses.
If we all knew what the direction of Trump's
presidency was going to be, why couldn't they
know?
We knew in 2016 when Trump was elected that
this was going to become an authoritarian
nightmare.
And Pat Toomey says, well, you know, other
than the mean tweets, it all seemed perfectly
reasonable at the time.
No.
And this is why I'm saying a lot of these
guys are doing this just out of self preservation.
And then lastly, longtime Trump loyalist Chris
Christie says if inciting to insurrection
isn't impeachment worthy, then I really don't
know what is now.
But if an impeachment resolution actually
comes to the floor, won't many Republicans
be hard pressed to oppose it?
Listen, I think they're all going to have
to vote their conscience and and look at what
happened, I mean, what we had was an incitement
to riot at the United States Capitol.
We have people killed.
And to me, there's not a whole lot of question
here.
So, you know.
So you think it was an impeachable offense
for George?
Oh, sure, yeah, and you'd vote to make, you
know, in the will, that's if I think it's
an impeachable offense.
That's exactly what I would do, George, but
I'm not in there.
But you want my opinion.
That's my opinion.
I don't.
I think if if inciting to insurrection isn't
that I don't really know what it is.
But I will say, too, that the Democrats, by
what they did earlier on Ukraine, have kind
of cheapened this a little bit, too.
So, you know, there's always a hedge.
And Chris Christie says Democrats cheapened
impeachment with Ukraine, but, yeah, he should
be impeached this time.
That's a big time Trump loyalist.
That's a powerful Republican figure.
That's a guy who was metaphorically and literally
behind Donald Trump for years, standing on
stage, sometimes looking a little sick from
the things Trump was saying.
But it's a big deal that Chris Christie now
says, yes, this is absolutely impeachable.
So there's no sympathy for any of these Republican
operatives.
They were behind Trump for years.
But it is important that it's also Republicans
this time to not because we need to allow
their image to be rehabilitated, but because
it confirms to us how bad things are that
even with the most radical Republican Party
we've arguably ever had, we are starting to
see some Republicans say it's time to go.
Yeah, it's pathetic.
It's only nine days to go.
I get it.
They don't get anything other than this does
signal how insane the situation has gotten.
But one guy who I guess is going down with
the ship is Republican Senator Lindsey Graham.
And I want to talk about him next.